exercising can make you a happier
chiller more sexually aroused person but
it can also be expensive and confusing
good news you can do these 12 totally
free exercises pretty much anywhere
anytime using nothing but your own
bodyweight so sorry you're out of
excuses
push up put your hands under your
shoulders and keep your feet hip width
apart keep your body in a straight line
from the back of your head to your hips
don't tilt your head or lift your butt
keep your elbows in and close to your
body throughout the movement planks like
a pushup
except you don't move your body should
be in a straight line tighten your core
tuck your chin look at the floor keep
your feet hip width apart squeeze your
ass and breathe to up the ante do plank
taps keep your body still as you tap
your left shoulder with your right hand
then tap your right shoulder with your
left hand carry on alternating between
hands and getting fit as glute bridge
lie on your back with your feet hip
width apart toes facing forward and your
knees bent contract your abs and push
through your heels to lift your hips off
the god floor there are four lunges you
need to know to change your life side
lunge by keeping your chest up shift
your weight through your mid foot and
heel while lunging as low as your
flexibility allows don't get sloppy and
let your knees travel forward past your
toes to do a reverse lunge start out
standing straight step one foot
backwards keeping your front knee at a
90-degree angle keep your chest up like
you've given and distribute your weight
evenly between your feet allow your back
need to lightly tap the floor and push
through your front heel as you stand up
spider lunges sound scary if you're
afraid of spiders but they're not start
at the top of a push-up position bring
your right foot to the outside of your
right hand landing with a flat foot
bring your foot back to plank and repeat
on the other side keep your shoulders
over your hands and your hips in line
with your body you got this dog jumping
lunges aren't for [ __ ] keep your
front knee at 90 degrees and lunge as
low as your flexibility allows without
the back knee touching the floor
seriously don't let it touch keep your
torso vertical as and your weight
distributed between your feet jump to
switch your feet land softly single leg
deadlift
keep your back flat your core tight and
your weight evenly distributed in your
planted leg raise one leg behind you
hinging at the hips with your toes
pointing down
don't be an M and only as low as your
flexibility allows pull yourself back to
stand using the hamstring of your
planted leg keep your head neutral keep
going squat put your feet somewhere
between hip and shoulder width apart
turn your toes out as needed keep your
chest tall and look ahead and slightly
up as you bend be sure your knees track
in line with your toes
squat only as deep as your flexibility
allows you know how deep that is when
you're feeling advanced it might be time
for the squat jump squat until your
thighs are parallel with the floor with
your chest up hold your arms straight as
you squat and push them behind your back
as you jump exhale as you jump as high
as you can can and land softly walkout
keeping your legs as straight as your
flexibility allows and your back flat
then at your waist and place your hands
on the floor in front of you keep your
core tight as you walk your hands out to
a plank position push your hips as high
as possible and press your heels into
the ground as you walk your hands back
in it's about the god journey after all
not the destination
you look fitter already